okay babies it's your boy psycho [ __ ]
babble okay and he is here with someone
walking two dead
okay okay yeah I got my coffee like it's
good you know
haters okay hey there's the usual my man
Jerry say last time he saw that my
[ __ ] brother who was like a li ttle
to do frontier and that doesn't change
anything the mission is the same kiss
Kate kill the brother okay I mean and
obviously on the walking dead
okay that's watch us what happen even
have to see this cup up anymore baby
grandpa yeah sleepy no yah yah yah yah
yah you don't know anything do you oh my
god oh my god oh no yah yah yah yah hey
shoot that [ __ ] Oh God cat
put your hands up and close your eyes ah
she's so badass think ah okay ah okay
okay hobby don't hey what do we call you
Paul flash a sec sorry forgot to
introduce myself
it's Paul but my friends call me Jesus I
[ __ ] knew you're one of them
you goddamn white shoes yeah we got pop
this sucker you want to shoot me shoot
me how about I feel bored playing here
instead I don't understand that
why didn't why do you look sad why do
you want to shoot the boyfriend about
him like what was she supposed to do
I transform what the hell is going on
out here
oh my god it's che c'è oh my god boxers
are all bundle up okay this scale adapts
the choices you make and the stories
tell it by how you play I had no idea
you know I thought this was very linear
keeping up so close to dark harder to
see them coming we're just gonna get
that propane and then come right back I
thought in that pickup truck parked down
the road a little in front of the
Wallace system I just wish there was an
easier way to get it I gotta kiss this
[ __ ] to risk life and limb nothing's
easy anymore Kate but that doesn't mean
we don't have to try I know it's just
hard to get used to
that's all we get over there we grab the
tank we get the hell back home if we're
lucky we won't see a single one of those
things fingers crossed
okay I want to kiss you on the lips so
hard that the back your head is going to
start the krinkle okay is that what you
wanted me to say because I said it okay
let's take it go okay I just take
getting out what else I hate when they
make me do like this really weird just
like TAS like there's only one thing I
do so it's like okay I see I gotta click
now you know like I was like it's just
the story changes okay kidding me oh my
Kate are you crazy you're gonna wake the
neighbors of course it's empty why would
we get that lucky hey hey don't beat
yourself up about it
it was worth a shot it just didn't work
out sorry
I'm just sick of this [ __ ] I just
thought
one time we deserve to catch a [ __ ]
break
why do you deserve that
oh I guess I'll kill this up maybe we'll
a I think oh yeah there's an a G your
hammer now I thought let me this guy oh
sure okay why aren't you giving a hammer
I'm sorry I was just [ __ ] scared
you froze it's okay I wanted to kill it
I really did I know him he doesn't
matter
keep friends true oh sweet
you boys had a smile on his face I'm
sorry you had to see that I'm sure he
was it good I gotta say anything I can
to get his panties keep one of those
things I don't even know what to call
them DeMarre dose if they're not people
if they're just the dead death 'martha
wife does oh I thought we were gonna die
I thought gaben Mariana we're just gonna
wake up we would just be gone
I'm right here okay I'm here you're here
was still alive that's what matters
kiss her kiss her can we go back now if
you kiss me [ __ ] aah what's going on
here has blown opportunity opportunity
okay nothing is more magic than just
telling it's [ __ ] some friends
allowed me thank every just saw your
friend you're out there yeah he's busy
right now but he said hi we all wanted
to stay here in the house and we / dated
to come back very minute our back three
months since he drove away with your mom
what are you saying we're not safe here
not anymore you and I could have been
killed out there
for an empty can Sam take out we-we've
go somewhere else
somewhere safer no more with crazy sick
walls okay and a gate that's 20 feet
tall you really think the kids are gonna
be happy with this plan the kids will
understand and if they don't we'll just
make them see it our way we have to go
well come let's [ __ ] small leave
we're safe inside the house we need to
find somewhere with more people around
people words still alive people who
don't mind sharing their supplies we
have our own supplies no no not anymore
what about dad not him I mean it here's
the father is he gonna think if he shows
up we just ditched him your dad would
want us to do this game he'd want us to
survive in surviving here at home Haley
I'm sorry Gabe but javi Frank how about
you guys go in I say here you're a kid
that's not how it works
I can take care of myself no you can't I
need any help I'll just ask my friends
what friends drew what we just might a
different row what's what's wrong with
her
why she acting so weird I'll tell you
when you're older okay just tell me I
can handle it I don't think so
we can't lie to him javi he needs to
know your friend drew from down the
street
keep he didn't make it
like I like capers like surprise one of
them who you understand why don't you
why we have to leave if that happened to
you I couldn't bear it
Marone the mom got shot my head we have
to go we were freaking out [ __ ]
tomorrow as soon as it's daylight I want
to leave him a note I'll help you get
started okay what are we gonna tell him
I want to say something good something
that will make him sad tell him we're
gonna be okay we're gonna stick together
and we're gonna get through this I will
not say I love my brother I was not okay
I'm gonna write it right now so we don't
forget
oh [ __ ] can you forget thank you
did you think that bear is gonna save me
on your shirt mommy and your uncle has
something to do in the back room
I am badly you better turn that picture
around
I have clogged the library the walking
dead okay
you better pack that thing
Oh
I got Louisville Slugger
I get that yogurt bye-bye oh yeah I get
that wave
hey Eddie ask my cha-cha adios
episode three above the law - that's
your lawyer in front the law put these
people away haters are uh they're always
gonna hate like anybody thinking that
haters are gonna stop eating one I like
know you'd death what they do that's
what defines them hey Dad
Bobby is it really you
[ __ ] [ __ ] kids on the ground I always
hoped I'd find you I can't [ __ ]
believe this
it's it's you gonna set it better myself
I knew you were still alive
I knew it tastes like hisses cat hey
weapons down
is my family a monster crush yeah you
got a lesson Kate doesn't have much
longer
Jesus now here now hit so now he knows
really I'm right here
what the hell happened she's been shot
and we got the bullet out but she's
still bleeding we need your doctor now
David what the [ __ ] is she on the ground
for she's barely got a pulse
she's cold as [ __ ] in height he said we
had to kneel I couldn't hold on to work
the [ __ ] you tryin to prove max they're
Outsiders David it's what we do with
everybody she's coming inside but she
hasn't been [ __ ] [ __ ] that this is my
wife I I didn't know
alrights going to the hospital now our
doctors gonna help you honey I'm gonna
make sure wait I'm going with you
sorry but the rest of you have to go
straight to quarantine what the why all
newcomers get checked for bites and they
all have to answer a couple of questions
our doctor will clear the two of them
but the rest of you have to come with me
to the quarantine holding area if Kate's
going to the hospital it's so am I not
yet first you go through quarantine then
we'll be I'm gonna have to fight that
[ __ ] [ __ ]
come on hey David you [ __ ] [ __ ]
let's go
it looks like I got a quell day event
and now like people think psychobabble
get enjoyment out of count all is people
but I just know like they push my hand
you know alright and locker room again
Oh Alan our trap okay we found the car
without you in it
didn't know what to think and I'd I came
here looking for help and this happened
I've been so worried about Kate I told
him [ __ ] a left her in a car they
promised me someone will look into it
luckily we found her before she got any
worse they just took her to the hospital
I can't believe no one went to look for
her
I'm sorry javi really but I didn't have
any reason not to believe him
what the people here in Richmond their
new frontier oh my god oh my god we
didn't even heard the worst part yet one
of them's his brother the later I didn't
even know you had a brother
hobby hey nobody's more surprising me I
thought the guy was dead we haven't seen
David in years it's just been me Kate
and the kids this whole time I don't
even want to think about what the odds
are but he did seem pretty damn
surprised to see you whoever this guy is
he can't be all bad she's pretty crazy
but I'm well I'm gonna get him dad don't
worry
he helps case instead of hauling her
down here of course he brought her
inside
she's just damned why you're kidding
kate is married to your brother the way
you act it around each other let's just
say it's complicated
alright maybe it's my fault for jumping
to conclusions makes sense you'd be so
close considering considering a quad
penis at her once
family drama side hope you know I'm not
about to make nice with new frontier I
know you didn't have much stake in
Prescott hobby but they burn that place
to the ground for no [ __ ] reason
after everything you folks told me I'm
guessing I'm not gonna find my people
alive hell hobby they killed her nice
shot Kate for all we know your brother
could have been behind it brother not
behind it he's just a [ __ ] it isn't
his idea in the first place
if he knew about it it's possible [ __ ]
I hate to admit it but there's a chance
he gave you I doubt he gave the chant he
I doubt he gave the order and if he was
just trying to get payback for what was
stolen but I just I needed to kill Davis
because I needed that clay when you knew
the [ __ ] [ __ ] get along if you
want to hear me say he's an [ __ ] fine
the biggest [ __ ] I know question is
is he a big enough [ __ ] to go along
with some of the [ __ ] they've done
definitely if I think about what
happened to Prescott he's got to answer
for it
they all do I owe that to Conrad I'm not
just gonna let things slide I've never
really been an opera kind of man we need
to look like we're playing along with
her instead perfect what they say for
now then when the time is right that's
when we demand justice Hey
hey I would have been here sooner but I
had to take care of something all right
now come on already
kids asking for it maybe you think it's
okay to keep a lady waiting lead the way
gladly
looks like the rules don't apply to
everyone huh that's right some people
get out of here early others stay alone
[ __ ] time just dropping David just
[ __ ] nail him it's more cookie this
one javi
just go
Kate's family I have to go you
understand go give her a hug for me okay
Eleanor tell her sorry I left her in the
damn car like that like a [ __ ] cat or
something just her in the [ __ ] car
like a cat or a marshmallow don't worry
all over there I'll be back for your
goodies soon enough trips is keeping it
safe and what Jesus is deal is one man
JC
you know or haze this I got stuck in the
hospital hope it's up that OSHA
standards okay go along with them for
now it doesn't sound good
ooh he heard that we have a process our
own way of doing things
your guys better not have a problem with
that they often go well for
troublemakers here no problem you won't
have to worry about that
didn't sound that way they just need
time to get used to things I hope you're
right why does I so shy mom
yeah gray I [ __ ] hate festivals where
are we going Kate as for you I thought
you'd want to check on her listen javi
Gabe he told me some pretty messed-up
things things I need your help wrapping
my head around he shouldn't have done
that
I wanted to tell you myself bad news is
bad news who cares who delivers it he
told me you lost Mariana just a few days
ago yeah your [ __ ] man shot off I'm
sorry David
she she's gone she got shot by your
[ __ ] man
he's strange grieving for the same
person twice like losing something you
didn't know you had what was she like
honey you're so little when we got
separated
who - my little girl become Mariana sawn
things it now other people didn't
she uh she told me she wanted to write
down her memories to keep them alive
after she was gone
sounds like her always was a dream how
oh by the way I [ __ ] ran shotta how it
happened she was just standing there
minding her own business she just found
her los headphones in the dirt she was
smiling and then someone put a bullet in
her head what kind of animal would just
open fire on her like that you're
adamant about with your mark my people
aren't in the habit of killing little
girls David I was there they shot Kate -
ask your buddy at the gate if he'll
believe me max was a part of this
max you're going down babby [ __ ] is
right I need details what the hell went
down out there I need to know exactly
what happened everything you remember
bastards knocked me out and threw me in
their truck I got away near this town
Prescott the same [ __ ] attacked us
there their leader flooded it with
walkers and tear gas leader a crazy bald
guy with a beard badger what the [ __ ]
have you done now I'm gonna handle that
stupid son of a [ __ ] okay do me a favor
keep this to yourself the politics here
they can get messy
hey Judith boss there's four of us that
run rich you need to impress the other
three where you'll be back on the road
by morning
trying to stir things up you and your
friends could have a very short stay I
can be impressive when I try I'll follow
your lead
thank you I run security here it was not
like my word is law
and she would badger doesn't make things
any easier well [ __ ] that girl who the
fresh meat oh why aren't it's like that
my brother hobby the baseball brother no
[ __ ]
one of the chances of you turning up on
the doorstep it's a pleasure to meet you
Ava
no is it now you didn't say he was a
gentleman David that's because he's not
Ava's my right hand if there's anyone
you can trust in Richmond it's her she's
a [ __ ] [ __ ]
that's for sure
that woman the [ __ ] soldier she was
the first person I met up with after you
and me got separated I never would have
made it without her Gabe said you went
back to the house at the start I'm sorry
I never found you it doesn't matter now
we found each other in the end well
matters to me come on I got routed out
of the city on the way to the hospital
it wasn't long before she caught my mom
I'm coming back into Baltimore so I
hooked up with my old unit
we thought we could build a safe zone
outside DC after what happened to my MA
and everyone else I thought you were all
dead
but you were taking care of him weren't
you mmm-hmm somehow you found a way the
day dad died I promised I'd stick around
be there for the family no can't my word
okay yeah they suck my dick now at the
end of the world but you finally grew up
this is where they're treating Kate
don't get comfortable I'm not staying
long I'm going in myself because I need
to kiss her great what's with all the
[ __ ] Flag America love flags Oh get
off okay it hey hey kid got everything
you need
uh yeah his voice that dark don't worry
check it out hobby noodles in a cup we
need to get you some real food stat turn
you into a soldier right javi I'm glad
you're okay
I was gonna say the same about you
uh-huh damn it's good to have you back
look at this family look at my wife
isn't she the most beautiful woman alive
come on with the lights off you could
mistake me for a walker
I have to agree the key word being alive
game oh no she's giving birth she's
giving birth
no no she's scaring mouth I'm fine I
just needed to talk to you alone oh good
good guy oh you're smart kick fish's
expired anyway the whole time on the
road why when I thought that was going
to die and walking inside me screaming
to get away from here let's go no I bet
you are killers David yeah I know what
you mean this place gives me the creeps
I'm glad to hear that I would afraid
you've been won over by the security are
you gonna sit on my deck or what then
you and me on the road coffee that's how
we've made it this far please promise me
we'll go back to that the first chance
we get this place
the cage I promise by the way Kate you
have my word
rest up you're gonna need your strength
thanks I feel better knowing we're in
this together but please hurry I I don't
want to be left alone here
alright oh how you doing sweetheart
David reported some pain its blast now
strange how it just comes and goes I
think she pulled her stitches when she
set up her stitches I doubt it but pain
often comes in waves with abdominal
wounds I'll give you something to take
the edge off in case it comes back oh
yeah like a high pot work I thought I'd
have to operate but all she needed was
IV fluids and some antibiotics how did
you find someone with skills like these
wound like this kills nine out of ten
whoever did this really knows this stuff
we got lucky we met a group with a medic
Eleanor just before Kate got chela in
the [ __ ] cage quarantine now she's
there now we should let her out I'll
vouch for agreed
I'll have Ava bring her here I want to
meet this Eleanor I'm sure she'll be an
asset to our community
you can vouch for the rest of them too
right it doesn't work that way but we'll
make the case for them soon and I have
to go meet some people now see if we
can't prove he's worth the dam oh god
they're gonna take real good care e okay
send my apologies David I won't be able
to make it to what feeling okay - his
dance recital
I just want to keep an eye on my patient
the others know my vote is with you come
on
remember what I said we meet these guys
keep what happened - Mariana to yourself
[ __ ] that chad is one of my guys and I
will handle him like I just get a little
tricky get a little tricky
hmmm alright say [ __ ] loading time
what the [ __ ] crashing ah okay okay look
pretty but it's all sugars there's no
substance it tastes pretty Clint that's
all that matters
ah the brother Bobby meet the guys
Clint runs food production the crops you
saw that's him and his people cousins
are bridge to the outside world
she handles contact with other
settlements pleased to meet you javi I
trust you've been treated well I hope
you haven't been handled too roughly
oh yeah the so you threw me and was
totally five-star I'm sorry about that
we have to be careful I'm sure you have
second badge we were just about to eat
Clint was trying to convince me of the
essential superiority of his creamed
spinach over my magnificent Black Forest
gateau it's no contest
the spinach has real nutritional value
hobby take a look at that table you tell
me what you'd rather put your belly a
[ __ ] spoon advantage from Quinn's
garden or a thanks delicacy by yours
truly
I'm with Quinn gotta eat your greens if
you want to grow up big and strong ah
exactly at least you be well I just [ __ ]
in her mouth and she's laughing please
make yourself comfortable okay okay
thank you so yeah okay psychobabble get
get company value straight talking so
please forgive me if I seem direct we're
usually pretty strict about who we open
our doors to your brother's word counts
for a lot
is that so the three of us and dr.
lingard make all the decisions here so
yeah people who choose to stay with us
they have to deal with us bossing them
around not saying you wouldn't but it
can be an adjustment
especially for more independent minded
there's no structure out there now
I always do what I'm told ask my older
brother you're gonna fit in well javi I
gotta see that already when Joan and I
met your brother he was trying his hand
at fruit fruit we found him slowly
murdering an orchard on the Shenandoah
River haughty [ __ ] huh I helped him
bring it back to life we had a good run
there for as long had Chet what happened
what always happened he trusted the
wrong damn people that's what led us to
start this wondering what this fine
piece of body art is all about that
looks pretty intense doesn't it hurt
it's burned into your flesh of course
it's [ __ ] hurt not of commitment yeah
I'm just symbol from your year abroad it
was a crude answer to a difficult
problem and it hasn't always worked
please understand we had a terrible
winter just after we moved here we we
lost a great deal loved ones who left
hold in our life video protecting my
people from that kind of pain that's
what keeps me awake at night it turned
me into a perpetual night out I know how
you feel and a half a batch seeing that
people I care about suffering a terrible
feeling
I just want to shield them from it all
it's a noble aim one was fighting for
yeah I guess Oh gonna take it and do it
here I sent for him since when does he
answer to you from what I hear he's
well-acquainted with your brother they
exchanged if you pull it outside our
walls
oh right is that right is there bad
blood between you and mess yeah max
[ __ ] psycho and they can't be worked
out I want to hear that from hobby I
don't have a problem with him he's all
right by me yeah
stay mere huh I don't buy it
max how does this start
don't look at him you have an obligation
to tell the truth
we caught him siphoning gas from one of
our vehicles max sorry David I know he's
family but your brother's a thief is it
true
it was [ __ ] abandoned I was
scavenging whatever I could find I had
no idea belong to you you just asked way
to giving it to you you were [ __ ]
around that that's not all
he shot Rufus in the back you did what
we found the body near the wrecker
Rufus's truck that never happened
it's your word against mine the only
difference is I got no reason to lie
this is who you're asking us to bow for
David seriously oh yeah you know we
can't just open our doors to killers
we're trying to build something
different here everything I did out
there was to protect my people that's
more than I can say for you what you
mean Harvey you have something to say no
no don't say it don't say it no that's
it that's right he knows what he done
there ain't nothing more to say it's
clear your brother doesn't belong here
javi and his people have to go
overreacting it was a scuffle over
supplies we've exiled people for less
sorry David your soldiers are already
wild enough we can't add more crazy to
the mix oh you [ __ ] and everyone in
quarantine to the gate give them a pack
with a bare minimum to survive
oh is this patch it's like an Ultron
look we can't fight this not now Kate
and Gabe will be safe here your doctor
friend too but the rest of you you're
gonna have to do what they say I'm sorry
I can't leave Kate Gabe alone they won't
be alone I'll be here to take care of
them know what vet you know but maybe I
can't down the road black [ __ ] just
stay alive okay
ooh oh it's a little tough
how do i I got to get my girl hey AB
there but also gonna [ __ ] Eleanor it's
so tough
oh [ __ ] a neck you're lucky I'm God your
[ __ ] eyes out with my thumbs
you hear me [ __ ] they give us up lies
ah fairness go stacked it he did they
said don't walking
what about Eleanor walk eat [ __ ] answer
my [ __ ] question
god dammit javi good totally let's go
holy [ __ ] do not [ __ ] this up
there's a settlement a few miles west of
here don't come back
[ __ ]
quick loss Eleanor we lost Kate now it's
a [ __ ] sausage fest out here okay
it's a [ __ ] so peel back there thought
you were gonna play along we trusted you
look we're not dead that's something
okay
that's a [ __ ] sure
not yet anyway let's just see what they
gave us knowing then it's probably a
butter knife and a stick of gum they
could have just shot us good Morgan once
ok save early ok let's say your openness
I was going for the zipper but alright
ah discipline that sells house oh ok
looks like a map I doubt they give one
everyone Ava did say David pack the bag
why the hell is it tied to a baseball
bat payment sense of humor was always
poorly timed what the [ __ ] look at luck
aunt Leigh ok this is us ok
there's Richmond that helps but we can't
go back there knowing where it is lets
us know where we are
ok what is this X pretty sure David
wants us to go there and if this is us
here and I think we can head along this
path just got a head north looks like
they're expanding some of these areas
are marked clear and to find north we
need to find the North Star or just
[ __ ] wait till dawn the [ __ ] on
that start it's Reed special right it's
a brighter the end of the Little Dipper
no that's the Big Dipper oh ok we need
to go this way what else so sleeping on
a whole log it flashlights not enough
weapons no food
we need to get one concave
Tripp come on what's up I can't lose
anyone else
I'm telling you I can't press God Conrad
maybe Eleanor you won't lose anyone else
I won't let that happen
hey they're pretty [ __ ] bad job E
sorry man
rough day say the least
I know you got my back and I got yours
of course
Tripp why you whine strip here does
anyone know I feel like we're never
actually friends with him he was like
friends with our friends and now that
our friends are gone like what's he
doing here like hey like scatter all
along little one scandal oh I like okay
that's gonna stay here we have a party
all about you but with that [ __ ]
rabbit
I gotta tell you man I thought you and
Kate were you know banging yes I put the
gift she was married to not you I ain't
judging mind you I'm just curious what's
the story that's a business I know but I
hey man
it's alright go for it let it out bet I
do have feelings for maybe I shouldn't
but that doesn't just make them go away
no harm in saying it he'll only real
harms and not saying it when you should
it's always a mess ain't it
what's that who you love who loves you
if they're one of the same or otherwise
and you're right goddamn mess and it
never quite washes out
I know Eleanor told you that she and I
were [ __ ] buddies at whatever we were
but that's over now
I respect her wishes I really do I just
wish my heart respected mine
that's ship recounting get up J say what
do you say Leavitt something today is
this what you got for us man listen
tell me that isn't what I think it is
about a quarter-mile I had in the same
way we are well we could hit walkers any
second
we better scoot
right [ __ ] we just [ __ ] walked into
it look alive people
I got them should you look dad I get it
right now James day net second girl
had a rough [ __ ] feet yeah my face come
on man move your ass you want a piece of
this huh you want to see advancing your
[Music]
let's tally with finding a brass bed all
right cue the backup Clementine
that's [ __ ] you down out here [ __ ]
[ __ ] girls law careful with this that
what I'm your kind of doubt we're even
now just [ __ ] jealous knocking
Lebanon the whoops I thought you were
getting out of here
I was but the walkers are everywhere I
had to cover myself and Walker guts to
get away come on we're heading to a
factory nearby should be safe I thought
you were going to Richmond new frontier
take you out doesn't surprise me
not one bit no thanks to David no thanks
at all even that [ __ ] still around
this is gonna sound really weird but
he's my brother
why yeah everyone's like setting us up
doesn't make any sense
wait we're going David City they're
supposed to be safe Clem
you can't trust him javi I learned that
the hard way what's the story Fox Brad
wanted to need people again I had
nowhere else to go
the new frontier gave me this and made
me one of them they promised they'd help
him little boy right that turned out to
be a lie okay we have no choice I guess
now except to crush the new frontier I
don't care what you look around real
quick
[ __ ] at that [ __ ] get the doctor yeah
Oh Shh oh my god she woulda shush of
[ __ ] mouth [ __ ] you have to be quiet
oh it's that crazy [ __ ] like Amaya
saying it's biotics I love that oh [ __ ]
okay
Kayla's pills vile here's what what sec
of take it
Wow someone have got my hand I don't
need that [ __ ] die you better why is she
doing it here he's gonna be crying like
crazy [ __ ] a lot isn't it
hello dr. lingard what's the matter with
you Clem please don't let vancomycin
that's the last of it it'll be wasted on
AJ I told you it could save someone's
life if you sir
anything to conceive except it can't I'm
sorry Claire I tried everything I really
did this will help him get better
nothing can help you boy now clam put
the drugs back before anyone finds out
you took oh yeah what they do to thieves
you put the trucks back Sanjay he's
right this will only make things worse
you shouldn't be over here what is that
in your hand
Sanka myocin best ever out of it don't
worry about it
I'm already putting them back Clem how
could you I said I'm putting them back
Yeah right
she's a goddamn thief hey nice taste oh
great
what's going on here we caught her
trying to take those drugs what the hell
Clem we already did everything we could
for that boy how could you betray our
trust like this do you think I trust you
your people can barely take care of
themselves let alone a sick child dare
you easy David you're told those drugs
wouldn't help that waste that'll cost
someone's life down the road someone in
this camp someone who contributes to our
survival
we opened our arms to you made you one
of us this is how you repay us by
stealing by putting yourself before the
group you're done here you broke our
rules Clem violated yeah you know what
[ __ ] you and [ __ ] the new frontier you
already did that's why you have to go
maybe we should give her another chance
don't fight me on this Paul [ __ ] happen
appalled what John would say if she were
here
I'm sorry Clem you brought this on
yourself come on AJ we don't need this
place anyway
aah he stays
take him with you that ship has sailed
get out of my [ __ ] way right now
Claire she's in no condition to travel
let him go climb you'll only drag you
down out there
yes second [ __ ] you monster
what about this what was it all for
don't forget I'm one of you not anymore
let her say goodbye we owe her that much
least betting that [ __ ] [ __ ] faith
you heard her
yes I can [ __ ] say what you needed
oh [ __ ] then you go perfect you mean
yeah you're a piece of work you know
that you deserve every day Wow Sakon
vicious that uh knishes
I thought AJ would be the one finally
no.11 tur Allah the one who did it start
I can't believe David would be so
heartless that's why I guess trusting
other people who the [ __ ] is David okay
I mean not David uh AJ can't remember
this you need a circle on the map Oh or
smelly friends are back right like heck
[Applause]
my god good let me care that's not bad
just let me get that up
I am i bab aims and push against this it
might give find a way in
it's not a second hurry up and find a
way in
well there's a car with no wheels oh
yeah [ __ ] [ __ ] this thing is strong
to be gone hurry it up turn up [ __ ]
[Music]
okay happy you gonna do anything
[Music]
that's right calm to raise it a little
but something's wrong with it jams or
some [ __ ]
maybe we can force it open with the
jacket
ok let's kill this best
yes they definitely filled room right
now they're [ __ ] crawl over and [ __ ]
how do you think I'm doing [ __ ]
that's it
we'll go any higher
I'll be ok hey you good
come on trick close the door
hurry get they got their Jack out of
there bet you I get that Jack out there
damn man that was too close
hopefully that door holds him
JC do you like [ __ ] eater anything
I'm here David no let that [ __ ] die
here like a [ __ ] baby killer in well
what the [ __ ]
don't make me do this clamp
shoulda trusted my gut about you we need
to barricade the door did you let him
turn tell me now I ain't [ __ ] they say
my beef we didn't have to worry about
that
what the hell does that mean he lived
Clem he lived
me sucking lying [ __ ] lying but how
he was dying Clem said so
AJ bounce back he was stronger than we
thought it was a miracle
Unum or kilo Selena [ __ ] lie I
wouldn't believe them either what you
believe doesn't change the fact AJ is
alive Clementine please I'm telling the
truth
tell us break where is AJ now I don't
know for sure
they [ __ ] kicked the match me dr.
lingard took care of the boy he'll know
how to find him [ __ ] [ __ ]
then I'm going back none of us are going
anywhere until the walkers clear yeah if
I can't fetch just [ __ ] that guy what's
your plan David we store vehicle up this
way
provisions I came to get your setup and
and say goodbye I don't want you to
worry about Kate and Gabe I'll take care
of my family from now on they're my
family they'll be safe with me
not happening David they're my family as
much as you or is that what you think
yeah last I checked
Kate was my wife and Gabe was my son
[ __ ] boarded up
you need something to buffer something
heavy there help me okay
wait a half-second where'd you find this
over there show me what the [ __ ] what
the [ __ ] going on what the hell is all
this
but he could come in handy don't want to
just take them but I might be going
crazy but I think these came from
Prescott that's bad to punch I don't
understand how all this got here if I
can god I know hey none of this stuff
was here before I don't have a damn
thing to do with it we've only ever kept
a few basic supplies here for scouts
come on David don't play dumb what are
you suggesting then I was part of
looting Prescott you must have known
something you think I condone this this
is bigger than just Prescott their
spoils from other towns here two towns I
heard got raided a while back there's
stuff here from the kingdom come
oh sorry the mica is that a Harrogate
Arden I do that little [ __ ] again just
to see your head pop you sure as hell
are stupid ain't you only just realizing
that now I told you Joan is on the
warpath last thing we need is people
getting wind of all this stuff look at
all this [ __ ] we're freakin rolling in
it
I'll give you that just glad we found
some more smokes and now we get to see
your head pop you piece of [ __ ] David I
thought better of you max I really did
save it come on man
we're unit it's [ __ ] toxic it
stop he's getting away goes my man JC
feel walking outside and [ __ ] majeure
now get that [ __ ] oh [ __ ] hey miss Ted
strong talking but oh [ __ ]
let's kill this [ __ ] q oh yeah Thank
You H oh it's not for any I guess
Oh Q again okay um oh I got first queue
again
that's interesting hey now rent all the
right keys it's just still having a hard
time I feel like you know you think if I
was doing good I think doing god but man
yeah I'll go spit-shining
yeah there oh yeah only time fetch huh
well it tastes more oh that one must
have [ __ ] hurt though trip is like
yeah you're like tap their havoc why and
I get that batch and I got home I just
shove that gas cam down your throat and
lit you up like a candle it's just where
did I like I got I could've made Oh
jelly monkey gardius Oh oops you you is
it my goddamn guts out
[ __ ] yeah fell there bet worst kind of
don't badger this is how it had to end
Oh bring it then see if I can it's like
a vicious not make it last
get it over with now I may get this to
make up suffragettes are you waiting for
we've got to move the point drawing it
out
yeah kill that [ __ ] once he's all yours
yes please
raiding looting you betrayed who we are
you betrayed Richmond Jamal David this
is Richmond what's that supposed to mean
what's that supposed to mean I got
nothing to say
there's no use holding out max the best
you can do is make things right we we
weren't doing it without support inside
Richmond mm okay who the doctor Joan was
in on it
Joan is that we did it on her orders she
hit Lucas
she said we needed it to survive I
wanted to let you in but she told me
you'd never go for it um I'm sorry he's
too late for sorry you bashed out of
[ __ ] please don't kill me I'll help
you I'll tell everyone a Richmond about
this I heard you get back inside
maybe he'll be useful you know thank you
thank you I'm doing this twofold one to
piss off David two to get back to cage
okay
and plus if I killed on a David just
going to tell [ __ ] cape and I've
murdered some [ __ ] so you know I'm
playing a long time you know the long
game okay epic
where's Lonnie he gave us the slip
hightailed it back towards Richmond son
of a [ __ ] if he warns Joan wasn't there
one more
Oh what good riddance that son of a
[ __ ] killed Mariana did that make you
feel better
I wouldn't shed me tears if I were you
damn right it did bastard deserved
everything he got
be careful javi act like a beast you
risk what makes you human
don't become a thing you hate Chiapas I
kept chasing my trust
if any of you had any brains you'd say
the same I'm sure you did the right
thing it does sometimes there's just no
other way to make things right my friend
took a crowbar to someone one oh [ __ ]
did he see someone the girl our people
need to know about what we found here
what about your missing friends I'm
surprised you care human life isn't
exactly high on your list of priorities
you [ __ ] owe that time to keep
looking they'd want me to get home and
warn them so that's what I'm gonna do
hey die lady do what you got to do we'll
be fine on our own depends what you mean
by fine I won't forget about you you
have my word
it's a shitstorm out there man I don't
see how you're gonna make it one step at
a time
as I say we need to get back to Richmond
fast
I have loved ones in there we both do we
all do
and we're out of there what's she say
fine I'm gonna tell her how I feel good
finish up the mess never washes out
might as well get neck-deep we're gonna
need allies enrichment
lingard and Clint they're our best bet
if I can get to them before Joan does
maybe we have a chance I know I was
ready to say goodbye before but I can't
do this without you can I count on you I
won't be able to pull this off myself
yeah I gotta alright but I expect
first-class treatment and we're done or
quarantine for me or my friends just the
red [ __ ] carpet of course whatever
you need
let's just get this done mm-hmm stretch
a blonde e-ring alarm they'll be without
a gate there's a way in round back
that'll get us around any centuries we
can take Badgers truck why the [ __ ] is
downhill mind there are way in come on
we got to get almonds not back this
[ __ ] is back see any [ __ ] zombie
now
oh no we're trapped okay I can't wait
for another [ __ ] spoiler alert really
cliffhanger
I gotta get Kate okay I'm thinking this
will go a lot better if we split up a
group this big can't exactly sneak
around particularly if they're expecting
felinors in there somewhere I'm going
after that Ling guard brought her to the
clinic that's your best bet
hobbie that's where you'll go to get
Kate and game gut and bring them to my
house it's the one with the raven on the
hitching post
who'll all meet up there after I pay a
little visit to Joan stay out of sight
as soon as I can get Kate and Gabe we'll
see you back at the house Hey I ain't
gonna see it have someone [ __ ]
believe
I'll scout ahead
and what about you Kahn I'm pretty sure
I've still got some friends in the new
frontier I say know where AJ is being
held they'll tell me as soon as I find
him taking that truck and getting the
hell out of here like a plan you are
owed a vehicle hell yeah
watch get the truck bar and David he may
be playing nice but I'd still watch your
back I fully expect I'm with you Glenn
he rubs me the wrong way
yeah brothers aren't supposed to rub
each other I'm gonna figure out what's
best for us huh I hope it involves
getting far away from here yeah I'm just
so tired when you know David is rubbing
me your instincts have been right most
of the time I know you'll make the right
call and I get the [ __ ] out of my sight
bet she talked too much I guess yeah
David said to hang a ride up at that
corner seems clear so far
let's move what are you doing here I
thought your [ __ ] just going any
Chinese sit here
you know javi Garcia you supply
shortstop for Baltimore that Javier
Garcia that's who we're looking for
wait I thought you was taken from
gambler so he's a gambler and a baseball
player anyway
sounds like some paranoid horseshit guys
a [ __ ] ball player
there's the Medical Center I gotta go
ninjas way back in here and stir up row
we go in we get down we take in games we
get out what about our friends there
doesn't exactly look like a welcoming
committee
we cover smoke break damage we need a
distraction
we tell them traction from life how's
your throwing arm perfect I like the way
ya thang trap what I think's a tidy echo
through its window we need to get the
fire crew or that [ __ ] could burn down
the block you kidding they just taken
out a window
take the trick didn't it
went to sell place the ban
so second place oh yeah oh yeah oh okay
oh yeah baby that's tip look at find out
tell her we have to move Kate you got it
I'll meet you here oh [ __ ] game I
gotta kill him - [ __ ] we thought you
were Howard super worried like a lot
okay damn you don't think ever gotta go
now oh okay I'm sorry they said you guys
were denied entry it's true we're on
borrowed time the people who run this
place they're ruthless we have to move
where's my dad is he coming there's no
time to explain now let's get to safety
first
oh okay David as a house in town he
thinks we'll be okay there do let's go
wait javi well you were gone
this woman Joan came by I could I felt
like she was hiding me up it was creepy
yeah Jay create a vet she lied David was
in trouble like he was no longer in
charge
she kept saying Dave and I didn't need
to worry but not only mazing or anymore
Joan's a shrewd operator you can't
believe a word she says
that doesn't exactly put me at ease it
shouldn't the folks who shot you
answer to her she ordered raids on other
settlements we found all this stuff from
Prescott she was behind Prescott mm-hmm
David's rounding up allies to confront
her right now
javi I know you know this already this
is not our fight
yeah we're gonna get the [ __ ] out of
here we already lost Mari because of
these pee
now the whole place is about to become a
war zone
the only thing I care about is keeping
you safe and you know we can't get
involved what's going on
Tripp said we having to David Tao we're
not doing that we're getting the [ __ ]
out of Richmond before it's too late
getting out you shouldn't even be
sitting up white what about my dad [ __ ]
it that just leave him Gabe we don't
even know who he is anymore we have to
get away before he gets us all killed
what he won't know where we are again
I'm sorry Gabe but we have to get out of
here okay beer [ __ ] up if we're leaving
subscride to get deep into the road so
all my stuff is stashed in the room they
gave me I don't trust her either I'll
come with you
I trust Jeff that with you guys Chris a
pretty girl David oh yeah
oh my BAE I got it come on buddy
I'm not going javi [ __ ] blank I'm gonna
find my dad I have to sorry Gabe no you
can't do that you're making mistake
like always mate you're always making
mistakes Gabe always know it no JD no
please Gabe please I never thought I
could be a mom I never thought I wanted
to be a mom until I met you and your
sister I'm begging you don't do this
it's my dad Kate I can't lose them again
I can't take you
Kate we need to go now
look at me Kate please ok Buras such a
[ __ ] like you're just a disgrace or
the whole family
holy [ __ ] [ __ ] up
ok be like the worst person that regular
stood like a deployment like
disappointment to rank I like you know
he's like the only thing worse than a
zombie apocalypse getting to know him
ok let's say yeah ok it's his father
Kate it's what he wants
and this is what you want what we want
Calvin medals another so close in the
last few years I I thought Gabe would
want to stay with us I really saw him as
my kid you can't take it personally Gabe
just misses his dad I get that it's just
hard to say goodbye no no no that's
pretty sending me sent hello to my penis
again I'd hold it there folks and I'd
consider explaining yourselves was
Radley evil I talk fast fast and clear
easy now we were just on our way out
that's him right the brother thought so
bring him in now trip help bang trap
chef what's the other guy doing just
like she runs she can't her stitches
why the [ __ ] did they just have walked
their way out grand games that tells
father I don't let you tone David if
this is about your brother don't pretend
like you don't know what this is about
you've got a lot to answer for me you
must be joking
what's this oh that's a lead him and his
lady friend me I asked you to get Kate
and Gabe safely not tuck your tail and
run were you really gonna desert me when
I needed you most
Richmond's not safe it's no place for an
injured woman and a boy so you were just
gonna leave me to it huh mm-hmm
where are they now girl got away no sign
of the kid we'll deal with this later
Davis smuggled your brother into
Richmond despite what we agreed clearly
you have no respect for any of us this
is serious David you know we can't let
this go shut your goddamn mouth Joan
we've heard enough of your life don't
can you what's this all about
she's been ordering raids on peaceful
communities
sending your men to murdering Luke rady
Joan is this true mm-hmm do I really
need to answer that
that's a serious charge you come in
swinging you better have proof piers
office it's low life was part of the
rape I
well max what do you have to say start
talking right now unless you want to
follow your friend
what's his friend again oh yeah the one
that [ __ ] got turned to like a pee
badger and Lonnie we ran the off off
Jones orders
god damn it max I'm washing my hands of
this man John
how could you your stupid vegetable soup
all these years or your stupid soup the
real question is how could I not what
would happen to us without your
fertilizer Clint or your pills Paul do
you think our community would survive I
did what I had to to ensure that we
would how do you think you could justify
this I know I can all of you remember
the winter how much we lost friends
lovers
latias like games always make the Asian
people like shield the bad guys I don't
get it I think I promised I would never
let that happen again
drugs we're just to keep us going till
Richmond reach sustainability we're so
close so close to our dreams do we
really want to risk it all by fighting
amongst ourselves we should all be on
the same side of this David on Richmond
side she's [ __ ] delusional building a
dream on the blood of innocents you
don't have to tell me brother we lost
money on us - don't worry how many
others lost their kids to doctors like
mom and happen again sorry David
it breaks my heart about your child it's
it's something I'm going to have to live
with
I see tranqs casserole is just [ __ ]
table take them
what the hell put them in a cell until I
can figure out what to do with him don't
you [ __ ] touch me
that's an order they don't take orders
from you anymore David you're done here
how is that lighter you put yourself
before the group duh [ __ ] yes sir choke
on your [ __ ] cake it was like [ __ ] by
the way that that was it
Paul's like David's like Paula that's
not necessary don't say that my hands
are tied this is not over Joe that cake
one really got in badly allies
that's a fact that's a [ __ ] oh they can
make us kiss that is messed up that is
messed up it's what David wants I could
be a won't stop rubbing me okay but I
have to software we're done here we're
down here now let's get up a sudden okay
I'll add your brothers request get my
hands match yourself a lot of you blurt
it out man I honored it and saved AJ Oh
a lot who don't risk using the medicine
getting hygienic whose [ __ ] kid is
alright you and 5% kill badger quickly
destroy badger skull in turn that's when
I was called a dream I don't know where
every time a rare breed brought max with
me okay good who decided with well we
should leave with Kate why would you not
leave with cage just [ __ ] hot I [ __ ]
like a puppy lips to enter the jelly
lips good good well anyway it's another
great episode another great episode
thank y'all for watching thank y'all for
watching thank ya